yo boulette cab show special guest
this guy man listen i've seen your song
in my head all [__] every day bro
i think you might have the catchy song
ever
i'm just walking around saying whoopty
uh yo
cj is here welcome sir yes sir
appreciate y'all for having me
are you tired of this song yet nah not
yet man i ain't gonna lie not yet a lot
of people ask me that question but it's
like
like i love performing this [__] you
know what i'm saying like
you feel the energy and the vibe of the
crowd it's just like a new feeling every
time
plus like you really ain't like uh
because of colvin and [__] you really
haven't been able to like really hit the
hit hit the pavement like you probably
would have if this
if this [__] wasn't going on exactly so
it's like
supposedly i think april 1st
everything's starting to really just
open back up
so we're getting more like i [__]
hope so cause i'm good me too
but we can't even eat inside over here
in l.a i know
i know it's crazy um
you're from staten island born and
raised in staten island yes sir wu-tang
is my favorite [__] group ever
yeah [__] what was saying heavy like
growing up in staten island is that like
a thing like you gotta [__] with woo
like you know what i'm saying i mean
yeah it was like it was a little before
my time i was born in 97 so i kind of
grew up
you were born the year that wu tang
forever came out yeah yeah
no yeah that's that's a classic but um
it's more like
i grew up in the early 2000s era so it
was kind of like when 50 first came out
you know i'm saying jay was hot
nah i see what i'm saying wayne started
you know becoming more popping
but um yeah i kind of i kind of really
didn't get to see that wu-tang era you
know they really they really was
probably like 94-95 of course
so being from staten island for people
who aren't from new york
we all we i feel like that's the borough
or the area that we probably
hear the least about right yeah they say
it's like the forgotten borough
i'm saying or they don't want to
consider us new york or whatever the
case may be you know
they're going to say whatever but um
yeah it's it's super hard to really make
it out you don't want to be here
you know a bunch of artists making it
out of stand island so it's kind of like
a blessing
is it like a you feel like you got an
extra chip on your shoulder because of
that like you had to work even harder
yeah for sure for sure we don't really
you know we don't we never really have
that spotlight on us you know what i'm
saying so
and we don't really have people backing
us up because like i said everybody was
you know cracking jokes on staten island
so we didn't really have that that
platform
but um you know now shed the light on it
so it's a beautiful thing
how long have you been rapping i've been
i've been rapping since i was young man
i want to say like
13 14 years old i'm saying just you know
having
little rhymes in my book and stuff like
that and really just you know starting
to freestyling in front of groups and
crowds
what about like when did you record your
first song like when you was like yo i'm
actually put some
effort and some money into this [__]
like my first song that i recorded
i might have been like around that age
like 13 14 i um
a old friend of mine you know uh we had
we had like a little laptop right and we
had a mic
so we was just like just playing with um
garage band
making songs on there you know i'm
saying and just playing them back and
kind of just like letting you know our
close friends hear it and understand
that's really it but yeah 13 14 i think
i started making my first
few songs will there be any um have you
seen that these jack harlow
videos coming out when he he was like 12
rapping
he was shooting hella videos when he was
a kid with his homies and they've like
all just kind of been
it's oh [__] this [__] just bugged out
oh [__] it did
yeah no that should've done let me see
that like that
i should just when they almost let me on
fire all up nah the whole [__] front
of the joint just straight exploded
this was the pre-roll shirt yeah it's a
privilege oh man who's who who's your
boy who's roland is he over there
yeah all right i need another blood soon
mm-hmm
i got all the joint all over his [__]
right there for me jesus what were you
talking about oh no i wasn't saying were
you like shooting videos and [__] back
then when he was a kid that may be like
now that you're popping might resurface
you think and now
not that i was shooting videos but
there's there's definitely videos out
there like
of me rapping i'm saying like maybe like
family members and close friends got it
you know i'm saying but um as far as
music videos i started doing that like
maybe a little older like 16 17.
do you remember um what what was the
moment
you realized that you had some real
momentum with this whoopty record was it
going to a certain club and hearing it
was it like a certain amount of numbers
that it hit online
like yeah it was probably like online
like i really started
like i started seeing the catcher buzz
online um
more like instagram and facebook and
like tick tock you know what i'm saying
like
booming on tick tock yeah it was
starting to start a booming on tick tock
heavy um
like there was a whoopty challenge that
was going on when i first did you did
you started or somebody else started
yeah i started it you know i'm saying i
started it like
like me and my little sister and you
know my girl we came up with
we came up with like a little dance to
it right saying i didn't really know
what tik tok was
like my little sister had to put me on
she was like yo like you know there's a
bunch of kids on there and you know they
doing dances and challenges and i was
like what's that
i made an account and um we did the
dance and i should just blew up
did you does your little sister i mean
did you like you know obviously
she kind of [__] put you on you know
being low-key yeah yeah i mean
no i just i just bought a car for her
for a birthday
what kind of car she was a little
starter car she she's only um she just
turned 18. you're smart
you know what i hate when i be seeing
rappers buying like they're 14 year old
kids like [__] lamborghinis and [__]
i'm like yo fam what are you doing
like you got to be practical yeah now
she's still learning how to drive and
all that so you know
start a call what about the rest of your
family if you think you've gotten
like like financially
you know you're doing a lot better than
you were doing so
have you noticed any a new family
stepping out um
yeah you know uh i see on instagram all
the time you know
you know second and third cousins you
know posting me all the time you know
posting
pictures that they found of me from
years ago like oh i love you cuz
keep doing your thing like like you
ain't even called me
for none of my damn birthdays you know
what i'm saying now you're welcome
but it is what it is i guess it comes
with the fame and all that but um
yeah now there's always you know new
family members popping up and stuff so
so you got the coke boys uh
chain on um how did you link up with
french
um me and french you know he just
reached out on some like
on some just embracing me you know and
showing love you know especially like
you know
a young artist coming out of new york he
was like yo i love what you're doing you
know i love the record
you know what i'm saying and um he was
like yo whenever
l.a you know come come by the crib he
kind of like just you know embraced me
and showed me love and
you know surprised me with the chain he
was like that's my gift to you and he ex
he executive produced my ep
so no i saw that um so are you official
are you signed to french or is you just
like honorary fam type [__] that was
just that's just family [__]
that's just him just you know showing
love french one of the coolest dudes man
yeah for sure
yeah that fool and then he's like in
shape now and [__]
well he's getting his work caught on
yeah you know friends used to kind of
have a dad bod like me so now i'm like
man
yeah yeah he's doing his thing for sure
do you have any kids
no i've got no kids not yet uh what do
you what it like
when you're at home when you're not you
know running around promoting your
record and performing and
you know being a superstar what do you
do in your free time
i like to travel you know i'm saying i
like to travel whenever i get some free
time like you know maybe like a week off
or whatever
i like to go travel i like traveling
going to different countries you know
snapping my back
what about while you're at the crib
while i'm at the crib probably just
playing games like you know i was
2k yeah i'm a 2k fan um ufc
you know what i'm saying we got the um
the fifa i like the fifa joint
did you do you see that guy getting neat
in the face over the weekend the guy
oh man it was that ufc fight was that
guy's name
this guy got a flying illegal knee to
the head and got
ko'd but since it was illegal he won the
belt
but got knocked out yeah and he was
crying and [__]
it was he was crying you're gonna cry in
the car i'll be i'll be kneeing i'll be
needing a lot of [__] in the ufc
in the game not in real life no no no no
no no
can you fight i could fight i didn't i
just you know some people like
didn't have to fight growing up so you
know before growing up you know i was a
pretty boy you know got all the girls
you know always had the flaw gear i had
to prove myself a lot of you know
try to test you always trying to test me
yeah i gotta jump before all of that
um what is your team on 2k
um i go a lot it's between like
i like the legos but i i always try to
keep it in new york then that's got a
squad
i was gonna say he's gonna say the nets
the nets got us that's [__] the cheat
code
yo right now they got a squad like i
think they of course it's the next they
even might
make it like they even might go there
you know what i'm saying if they don't
go there
it's it's no excuse bro yeah now they
they have to man
and they just got blake griffin oh man
yeah it's over
hmm we got a squad for sure we so you
claiming the nets yeah for sure anything
anything come out of new york but you
got you go you so you're saying the
knicks internets
whatever's coming out of new york right
now the nets is putting no
the nest is putting off from new york so
i'm gonna i'm gonna claim that the
knicks are uh in the they're in the
playoffs right now
yeah julius is an all-star yeah so like
i said i'm supporting anything coming
out of new york
when you were growing up it was the
knicks though obviously yeah for sure
because
back then it was new jersey nuts the new
jersey now
yeah we had um they had a kid
jason kidd keith van horn kenyon martin
jason williams carrie kittles yeah i
wasn't really a
i was i was not a nuts fan back then but
i'm a [__]
yeah to brooklyn so yeah you gotta get
you got to go hard
who are some of the other uh like big
homies besides french that have tapped
in with you that you've been
developing like friendships with um well
now it's more like latin artists right
now like
a lot of a lot of latin artists kind of
like they all just hit me at once like
like who like on well ozuna you know
what i'm saying we got some records
together um i just did some
some uh records with faruko and um i
don't know if y'all know alpha from vr
he's he's big out there but um yeah just
more like lan artists but um
you know cardi b reached out um you know
she showed she sent her love
offset reached out you know he sent his
love so
you know fat joe are you gonna start
making spanish music yeah for sure we
already in the process of that
fire that's a whole other like it's the
biggest [__] in the world low-key it's
bigger than hip-hop like
like numbers international you know what
i'm saying because you know now you
talking
you know brazil colombia cuba you know
what i'm saying mexico
so it's like it's bigger than the u.s
what's your ethnicity
puerto rican puerto rican okay yeah have
you you've been to the dr
yeah i've been to the fire super fire
yeah what part did you go to
um i went to um la la romana
it's um it's like an hour away from the
capitol
i'm in the putacana shauna yeah i've
never been there before
what's it like how do you compare the
difference between like
puerto rico and dr as far as vibe um and
we was just talking about this too
puerto rico is like well well now it's
like a little more americanized
right what i'm saying like like they
still like they still paying in american
dollars you know what i'm saying like
it's more americanized now but if you go
like deeper into puerto rico
it's going to be the same vibe as
dominican republic
yo did you ever try to um
mama wanna drink in dr moana uh
they got this [__] like drink that
they make at home
and and it's like a dominican thing it's
called mama wanna and it's supposed to
be like
they call it dominican viagra but it's
alcohol i heard about that [__] i ain't
gonna lie
there's like little it's like a bottle
and it's like pieces of wood in the
bottom it's [__] crazy
i heard about that i never tried it but
i heard about that like a viagra drink
it's like viagra bro you be taking shots
of the [__] mama juan you ever had
the mama wanna
of course yeah no it's like it's it's
like a shot bro it's like getting a shot
of tequila or something but it's like
they're
it's like if you go into the dr you got
to have the el presidente beer
blew up on me did you blow out instead
of in
nah like i was just regularly smoking
this [__]
jesus christ well what brand is this
some free [__] they got dropped off [__]
they got to make they
they uh papers a little tighter that was
terrible
that was i was alarming what's the
highest you've ever been in life
do you remember a time the highest i've
ever been in life
i was young i was like 15 15 years old
14 years old
and um i was smoking with a few friends
of mine
and it was like two girls they was from
out of state right i think it was from
like pennsylvania or something like that
and um i'm not sure if they put
something in the weed or whatever the
case may be i don't know how they get
high
but um we took a full a few drags or
whatever
and then we went outside and i just felt
like i started tripping like it was
raining outside
and then i was walking home and every
time i would look back i would see the
same house
for like maybe like 20 30 minutes jesus
literally like i'll be walking and i'll
turn around and see the same crib like
following me
so i'll just be like i'm bugging out
like i'll make it back home oh my god
i might have just had a bad heart sound
but have you ever done any um
hallucinogenic drugs nah nah like
mushrooms or something
i never did anything outside of outside
of weed like i never did coke i never
did i've never done coke or pills either
but you should try some shrooms shrooms
i heard
everybody keep talking about some
shrooms but i'm straight they took them
on some third eyes [__] i'm going with
two yeah now you're like it like
you won't i mean but you want to have a
third eye if you can not straight man
god made me with two eyes for a reason i
don't need no third
i'm straight man if he one of me with
three guys he would have made me for
three eyes
so the ep is out um is the album being
worked on
yeah 100 we end up in the um in the
works of the album right now should be
dropping summertime
is the album gonna be um like are you
gonna introduce the spanish [__] on the
album
yeah it is definitely for sure it's
definitely even on the arm because we're
gonna probably drop an enhanced ep
so it's gonna be like a few songs on
that we're probably going to switch it
up and throw some spanish joints on it
facts is there going to you got the new
record bob you already is there a remix
in the works already
on the remix not yet yeah not right now
like it's
like it's starting to ring off right now
like people are starting to like pick up
on it
but um yeah everybody the clubs is going
crazy to bob but radio is going crazy to
bob so bob is showing
showing some uh some movement was it um
like we talked earlier about you coming
out of staten island
and house it was like a little bit
harder do you feel like
being uh like because the record that
that you released is technically some
drill [__] right
um you're like the first dude in that
space that was like that's like latino
at least from from
my you know yeah um was that what did
that make it a little bit harder as well
yeah um the fact that i i don't know if
i am the first
latin drill artist well i don't really
consider myself a joe artist but
that was a drill rat that's a record
yeah on that type of style but um yeah
it definitely is a little harder because
it's like
like they don't believe it you know what
i'm saying like some people don't
believe it like oh like you know who's
the spanish kid around
you know a bunch of dudes in the video
you know they didn't really believe it
but um
you know what is what it is you know i
just love making great music you know
i'm saying i don't really care about
you know the negative stuff that people
are saying so i just be focused
yeah i felt like uh you had a lot of
haters for sure
i feel like i'll be on instagram and be
like this some i don't even know who any
of these people were
for it wasn't like nobody notoriety
mm-hmm but i'd be scrolling to some
random ass rapper or some dude [__] i'm
like what the what did this kid do
yeah everybody like i'm like a target
right now you know but that's i feel
like that's what happens with you know
that that comes with the territory you
know i'm saying when you hot when you
got a
number one record and you got a record
on billboard you know people going
you know they're going to hate who's
somebody who um
you like cause you have a song like
yours is so big that you know you might
even hear it on ellen or some [__] right
like
hopefully you know what i mean like it's
that big like the pop stations are
starting to play you number one at urban
rhythm which is a big deal
hard to do shout out to brandon scales
when i heard that [__] on z100 i was
like oh yeah i got a hit
all right right like it was on z100 you
know if there's some rap [__] on z100
it's got to be
that's like honestly like that might
have been the first drill record ever
played on z100 like who
whoever got on z100 that's in that lane
i saw i was going to ask you like where
did you hear your song where you were
like oh [__]
yeah that way i think i just got off of
a flight i hopped in the car
and um somebody shot i think my manager
a text and he was like yo
he's playing on z100 we tuned in and
actually was that as planned
damn um since you've been quote unquote
famous
what's what's some of the wildest things
you've experienced uh as somebody who
is no longer just a you know a civilian
if you will
um well like i haven't really
experienced no wild wild [__] because
like
like we was talking about before like
the [__] ain't all the way open yeah it
ain't all the way open so it's more like
just social media [__] you know what i'm
saying like
people just be you know sending wild
[__] on instagram
like like when you say wild [__] what
are we talking about
just ruthless [__] like i'm saying like
like girls don't even be caring
oh it's okay so girls will float you the
whole [__] just in the dm the whole
thing like everything like no filter
like
straight did any anybody ever dm you
like their only fans and say here's a
free code for a subscription come tap it
or something
um not that i know of but um [__]
it won't even be links to only fans like
you don't even have to i don't even got
to click on the only fans like they send
them oh they're just sending you they're
sending you the only offense to your dm
exactly so it's like it's a bunch of
that i'm saying and just
crazy [__] i be saying ugh that's gr
have you ever subscribed to only fans
account
no never would you do an only fans
account because you know tiger's tiger
low key got [__] booming right now
he's making his coins but um like he's
got his little um
like me it's like he manages these girls
yeah yeah i've seen i think that
that's that's that's dope but he does
but um whatever he clear he's his dick's
on there too
oh no i never yeah i never told that i
accidentally saw it on twitter ah
man yeah i never seen i never i never
tuned into this [__] but i know he got
like the
girls that he's managing but um would i
ever do only fans nah
i don't think nah i would never do it
fat joe and khalid have one
pause bro they do
they have one no they have one together
yo yo joe that's my man but oh
now they're on there like [__]
playing horse and playing basketball
and it's free okay okay he said that
that makes sense
because when i think only fans i think
you think they on there [__] yeah
that should sound crazy said fat joe and
dj khaled have a homie
together it's like their page nah but
not yet so if that's the case that's
yeah that's cool but other than that i'm
messing with the only family
yeah shout out to fat joe
hey man hey look yeah let's off the paw
[__]
man who do you want to work with that
you haven't worked with yet
um i think i'm out there locking with
boogie either tonight or tomorrow hey
boogie
booger yeah okay we're gonna do some
[__] for new york for sure put on
you know me and jay i got some [__]
coming out
um that guy's a nice guy very short but
very nice
yo we say that [__] at the time i love
jay bro i swear to god i was like wait
how do you
we got it we had a show with him you
sure you ain't 14. yeah
we got to show him in tampa i see i seen
him and now that's my god
no he's a nice kid for sure but um i
just did two joints with fredo bang
shout out to fredo that's my dog super
dope um
you know and we're just trying to you
know lock in more features right now and
then
like i said i got some [__] with you
know with the spanish guys
yes sir uh who in your opinion because
you mentioned the name a boogie and i
think a boogie
uh in the last you know seven eight
years
could be considered someone who you
could call the king of new york but who
do you think is the king of new york
the king of new york when it comes to
this rap [__]
right now i think all times you think
all the time is jay
it's jay that's something i'll write i
could give it up to
no i ain't gonna lie like everybody
anybody coming out of new york they
doing their thing but
to really like get called the king of
new york or even like
crown somebody to king new york you
really gotta like put in work and i
don't even think
longevity is yeah longevity i'm saying
like you
oh yeah nah you gotta you gotta really
show him prove you know what i'm saying
but um
nah still in my eyes jay i mean he made
400 million dollars like two weeks ago
so
cool oh yeah that's what i'm saying like
it's like
all of that mixed in one like what i'm
saying that's that's some king [__]
damn what about your your personal
favorite
like like growing up who who's in your
top five my top five i gotta say like
like i said i grew up in the early 2000
era so
i was listening to a lot of 50. but they
first came out
um jay obviously you know um
nas wayne and
i would say like i ain't gonna lie like
i start as i started getting older i was
listening to drake a lot
oh yeah yeah drake's you know i throw
him in there yeah yeah of course
you talked about uh tapping with fat joe
earlier not on only
don't only fans not only fans um he
he's kind of i think historically
uh you know we've looked at fat joe as
kind of like
i would say the underrated dude out of
new york like i feel like he don't get
enough love
and um the longevity is crazy but what
i've appreciated about him is
he's always giving game to a lot of
young rappers you know what i'm saying
like we remember that famous clip with
six
nine or you know whoever he'd be going
he's always just giving up free game
because he's been through it all did he
give you any game
yeah for sure we had um we had the
audrey live with fajo
i'm saying so soon as we you know locked
in with him
he was basically you know feeding me
some jams and you know telling me the
ins and outs anything that stuck with
you
um just like more importantly like just
like safety you know what i'm saying
like yo
a lot of these young cats is dying over
you know stupidity
and gun violence and stuff stuff like
that so you know just watch your
surroundings and
basically you know just just be safe
yeah man do you feel like it because you
hear a lot of people say like
rappers are the biggest targets nowadays
do you feel like that's true 100
because you know who else is really
walking around with
you know a bunch of money on them and a
bunch of jewelry on them
you know what i'm saying and they
risking their life every time they you
know go and do a show and
you know traveling in different states
and performing in front of people like
so it's like i would say one of the most
dangerous jobs out here
how how because especially in the last
you know 12 months
we've lost a lot of people to gun
violence and just i mean even like
you know a couple years ago x was just
shopping for a motorcycle
yeah in his hometown and they got him in
his car and robbed him you know
does are you very conscious with the way
you move and like you know what i'm
saying like making sure you
you ain't always like you know what i'm
saying like it's it's crazy how
they downplay you on having security i'm
saying but
a lot of these rappers that's dying
nowadays then i have security with them
you know i'm saying so how you
downplaying somebody for having security
and being safe
but if you don't have security you're
risking your life it's almost like you
get you damned if you do your damned if
you don't
i'd rather be with security i'm straight
that's some real ass [__] man
so you say that album's coming out
summertime summertime how is it done
nah that's not done no no no no
definitely not
uh is there anybody who you're trying to
get on the project right now that you
know
is is looking good like we could like we
could do a little endorsement on camera
you know what i'm saying send it to him
like
um just like like i said we're gonna
have we're gonna have a variety of
different artists on there you know
there's gonna be latin artists on there
there's gonna be some female artists on
there
you know what i'm saying and we just
locking in with more artists right now
we're just cooking up and you know
building relationships right now
you got to do some [__] with like
somebody from shaolin like from from
from oh yeah that's already in
conversation for sure um ghost face
ghost face would be crazy me and him we
just was on facetime like last week so
we about to lock in
that's some real staten island [__]
right there sir ghostface
like prior to like did you ever listen
to ghost face growing up yeah i mean
like i said i
like my mom played a lot of wu tang in
the house you know what i'm saying when
i was young young so
i definitely you know i [__] with um you
know ice cream
cream you know all right um i know a
couple of joints but um
i was i was a fan of them all right so
you're gonna leave the interview
you're gonna sign up for only fans
you're gonna support fat joe and dj
khaled
they're good men it's like a lethal
weapon with it's there like mel gibson
and danny glover they're in there
[__] shooting hoops playing horse all
kinds of good [__] i support whatever
fat joe do man latin brother brother
fair enough what have you tapped in with
khalid khalid and i haven't got the
chance to uh to meet him yet but
he reached out he said he was like yo
whenever y'all miami come come by the
crabs well look let's let's get into
your new record because we already know
about whoopty yes sir
whoopty's going [__] crazy let's get
introduce your new record man yo what's
going on it's your boy cj
yo we locked in right now tuning in to
bob my new single let's go